two men on that welcome the fat man on
Batman I'm Kevin Spence I'm mark barnard
oh my god we were so [ __ ] live
tonight right here at the scum and
villainy Cantina this beautiful bar
right on Hollywood Boulevard in
Hollywood California put your hands
together so the folks at home know your
real
and how have you been sir I'm doing I
write the the not dead yet tour
continues yes I know the feeling on
Sunday it was three weeks since I almost
died I was like right on I got to
celebrate in a very specific way
watch Degrassi what year what's your
week been spent doing it has been spent
watching Jessica Jones season two really
yeah yeah I'm 77 oh [ __ ] yeah things may
be happening that yeah by that what how
many episodes told 13 13 yeah and so far
so good it's a slow burn and I'm saying
that in the most positive way that I can
hmm we'll get there I swear to God they
do like to pull the taffy on those shows
yeah much stronger at 10:00 tight but
whatever I guess you know like we don't
make it up money at 10:13 it's gotta be
some sort of a dollar figure attached to
doing that money more cuz you know it's
not them gone no seriously we need 13
hours to tell this story no I saw the
defenders no you didn't but yeah like
there's there's still nobody on the
stage that's as magnetic as kilgrave was
well [ __ ] that's right yeah which is you
know a problem but you know [ __ ] I'm
here for Jessica Jones I mean for that
story I'm here for for this kind of
pious PTSD narrative and they do it very
well
I just wish a little bit more what
happened a little bit faster and and
more punching I think yeah punching is
good
I vote punching let me ask you this yeah
the first season all female directors
yes do you notice the difference at all
nope I mean it's it's just like a bunch
of dudes did it except it's a bunch of
ladies there are however you can tell
that there's not as many gratuitous
shots of like but there's a whole bit
I'm gonna I'm gonna spoil it a little
bit in that the lawyer that
what's-her-face from the matrix what's
your name again oh yeah cariann loss
she goes on this like crazy drug-fueled
lesbian bender which I mean it's the
highlight of episode three but now we're
getting somewhere
there's a version of that sequence that
is way more lascivious that is way more
objectifying that is way more about the
sex right where is this version of it is
way more about the spiral that this
character's going down and I think that
given the female gaze through which
we're seeing all of this show it was
handled with it with a sense of
sensitivity that I think you might not
have gotten different it's about a
difference I'm not lying I mean it's not
Jessica Jones but I since The Avengers
trailer dropped the other day I watched
the Marvel movies again you just so
[ __ ] excited I'm gonna watch the
whole [ __ ] story unfold and [ __ ] I
was like this will take me all month two
days so I rewatched it like I rewatched
Avengers and age of Ultron like the
Doctor Strange it went deep and went
back to Thor dark world and stuff mew
mew and and in the avengers there's I
never noticed it before but there's a
couple kind of like not gratuitous but
like clearly let's frame the black
widows ass in this shot that that like
stuck out to me like a sore thumb this
viewing around a way where I'm like I'm
offended and I have a daughter or some
such [ __ ] like that but I was just like
oh I had no idea but here's the other
thing I [ __ ] notice there is a
gratuitous man titty shot in every one
of those Marvel movies everyone takes
their [ __ ] shirt oh that's how you
get to be a lead and they won't let you
be the lead unless you like you take
your [ __ ] shirt off it's like high
school all over again
yeah Renner no shirt off Falcon no shirt
off Don Cheadle no shirt off right now
none of those mother novel star not the
star man
supporting characters they get to keep
their shirt on you know they've
graduated to the [ __ ] you know
premier character at the moment they're
like look at it it's crazy man they find
a way to get a shirt off a dude like
it's an 80s horror movies to find a way
to get a shirt off of a girl and I guess
that's a big part of it I'm certainly
not offended by it it's just very
noticeable but then I remember like
consider the source material like you
know where the [ __ ] comes from people
are drawn impossibly huge and [ __ ] and
so somebody builds their body that much
like I think [ __ ] Chris Evans like I
don't think that's CG I think that's his
muscle that's that dude well there's the
scene in in the First Avenger where
where what's a race Peggy she touches
his PEC she was not on the script that
was just a oh my god I don't believe
your body looks like that that's an
improv she made that up on the spot
she said that somewhere yeah yeah like
that's just oh my god look I want to
touch it
i'ma touch it stop me I dare you I'm
Peggy [ __ ] Carter goddammit he when
Yuri watch all the movies that he also
pushes through as an absolutely bright
shining star he was such a [ __ ] I
never give a [ __ ] about Captain America
in comics form like just boring at your
granddad's [ __ ] here own [ __ ] but he
made that hero into like somebody I
legit care about and have enjoyed the
story of that characters arc speaking of
which the Avengers trailer which dropped
last week and we've spent all weekend re
watching and re watching there's that
moment in the trailer where cap and
fanos throw down and Thanos throws a
punch and cap catches it and you see the
[ __ ] size of the Infinity Gauntlet
and the size that they're playing Thanos
for and stuff which is the comic-book
relationship it's like Oprah and work
all the time but fan oohs yes I just
make it a relative for everybody else
big but cap catches that [ __ ] punch
and then holds it and they cut to Thanos
who like literally looks like what how
is this [ __ ] possible and they cut
back to cap who's just like not even cap
anymore it's just Steve Roger
and it takes you right back to Captain
America the First Avenger when the
doctor was just like well you know do
you want to kill Nazis and it's like one
of the greatest moments in a Marvel
movie it's so [ __ ] poignant where he
goes no I don't want to kill he goes no
sir I don't want to kill anybody
I just don't like bullies I don't care
where they're from and that moment in
the trailer where he's taking on the
ultimate bully and holding his [ __ ]
fist like just made me roll it here and
then rewatch all the movies since I was
a goddammit man they've been playing
this [ __ ] it's a long con like 10
years of telling that [ __ ] story is a
lot of track and I've traveled on those
tracks and a lot of those moments men
get paid off even and watching the
trailer so the trailer was massive what
would you I I agree with you doing that
that moment is the you know I could do
this all day like I am the [ __ ] kid
from Brooklyn and I will always get up
and I will always look you'll knock me
down as much as you want I'm never gonna
stay down they make it look like in the
trailer he's definitely the one that's
gonna die
yeah
but then I think well that's what
they're making it look like that [ __ ]
pull you away from who to real deaths
gonna be don't restart probably right
and Hawkeye who's not even in the [ __ ]
trail yeah feel like you know how we'll
save a lot of money he just died before
the movie stuff he was in the woods and
[ __ ] with his family and he was loved to
death it's a dark day for the resistance
that guy died that'd be amazing man if
they're like really serious about this
[ __ ] Avengers movie like
[ __ ] are gonna die it would be
amazing if the opening was Thanos
crashing into Hawkeye's house and she
just Whedon's like why did I spend all
that time there yeah it just looks
[ __ ] better and better and better man
that's probably the last new footage
received for its release I mean it's out
and what's five weeks yeah oh my god
it's so [ __ ] close I did not rewatch
all the movies because I like glutton
for punishment is maybe the word I
bought the hundred dollar ticket for the
11:00 movie marathon at the El Cap what
is that that it's star get a medal at
the end of it they give you a medal you
should get a spine transplant after that
if I got to sit in those seats for 29
hours 29 hours it starts Wednesday at 1
o'clock ok and goes all the way until
Thursday at 6 when they show you it's
like an infinity war an hour early so
yeah they split is there food involved
there are there's there are meal breaks
there are what do you mean meal breaks
think you got an hour to leave the
theater but then come back it's yeah
it's a sword in green you just eat the
people who couldn't survive long enough
[Applause]
the so weight is you once you buy the
ticket do you get the metal or they they
make you be sure that you sat through
all like hey bet you left your in the
dark you got to sit through all of them
right to get the actual [ __ ] there
only be 11 of them they're only doing I
think it's like the first appearances
all right Eric ters that will play in
this so they're not doing Thor two they
are not doing so they are because yeah
that's the first appearance of black
panther oh my god they're gonna lean
into economy yeah and that latest
trailer is just like Black Panther to
welcome people Katya Avengers yeah it's
very it's leaning into it but so much so
that I guarantee you man like two three
months ago I doubt they put Sheree in
that trailer but that movie was so huge
her character played so huge they're
like let's throw a Sheree shot in here
man like why wouldn't you for Christ's
sake by the end of this week
Black Panther will be the
highest-grossing superhero movie ever in
North America really what did it have to
be Dark Avengers
oh [ __ ] he's about to pass the Avengers
Avengers is at 6:21 and black man
there's at 6:05 will it catch it that's
huge
will it catch it worldwide I don't think
it'll catch a worldwide janna worldwide
it said 1.2 billion
and Avengers is like 1.8 a 1.9 how did
it really go that far yeah but well I
should say why having just rewashed the
movie like it's a [ __ ] ton of good times
man and seeing all those characters put
together and giving them good reasons to
fight right off the bat and [ __ ] like
that so it wasn't this like oh they
don't like each other like it kind of
makes sense and then bringing them
together the only thing is like they go
well out of their way you know to
[ __ ] kill Agent Coulson and then
they're like you know see them Tuesday
nights on ABC do you think in the an
infinity war like that gets addressed
I mean they've five [ __ ] seasons of
that show and apparently nobody knows
that he's still
and everybody involved in in [ __ ]
Michelle like all the characters that
surround him must be like yeah I'm sure
you knew the Avengers feel like he's
like no I was in the first movie like
when I can open eyes these [ __ ]
yeah we went to space remember we
couldn't get home maybe gonna call the
[ __ ] Avenger to come and get us
no [ __ ] you Phil Coulson or in a world
where the like [ __ ] characters are
gonna die they reek ill cult for Coulson
Abed dead once it's very liberating I
went to UT you should try deep cuts we
let's use that to transition in terms of
the language of pop culture which we all
speak and this show really doesn't exist
without it really Marc and I saw a movie
tonight it was a sexy movie it was a
dazzling film it is a movie by which
like you go off [ __ ] that's a movie it's
one of those movies where I watch it and
I go oh it's so laughable I ever called
myself a director because the person who
made this movie is truly a director and
this guy's been entertaining us since
our wee childhood and still working
today and he [ __ ] crushed it this
time around we went and saw ready player
one
yeah [ __ ] sucks no it's amaze it is
it is amazing it's astounding it's I I
did not read the book I love that I'm
name checked in the book I'm flattered
but I'm honestly this is I'm going to
show my ignorance I'm not a huge book
reader so I never read the book good
friend of mine did told me every [ __ ]
thing about it and stuff so I know a lot
going into the movie I know the language
in the movie even though I never went to
the country so to speak but they make it
easy going into this movie even if you
didn't know the book because it's
sometimes they work conceptually rather
than from the [ __ ] page it is it's
it's a celebration of [ __ ] pop
culture of love of movies and shared
experiences video games and [ __ ] it's
certainly not like the trailer paints it
as kind of like every [ __ ] frame
you're gonna see Donald Duck [ __ ]
meet you know [ __ ] Angela from spawn
or something like that but they are
scattered yet throughout like like like
just they create a world where at one
point you're watching characters walk
past other characters are very small and
you're like holy [ __ ] was that Hello
Kitty and then they're on to something
else so that's there it's never
distracting it's all like fluent and
part of the story but it is it's like a
kind of modern day of Willy Wonka yes
sir
yeah the spine seemed certainly borrowed
from it but it's a movie that I spent
like most of the screening going oh like
that because they would do things that
just [ __ ] tapped right into you know
your nostalgia amygdala instead of
getting scared you get nostalgic and
they went right into it with so many
[ __ ] beats and moments and music and
stuff I loved it I absolutely had a
[ __ ] blast we brought my kid and her
boyfriend and she loved it too and I'm
like do you know who all those
characters are and she's like no I just
thought it was a really great movie she
likes the girl who was the girl
one of the girls and thoroughbreds as
well but [ __ ] dazzling man what a
trip down a rabbit all I don't want to
spoil it but everybody knows the book
kind of follows the story which I
thought was imagined to this [ __ ] man
everybody living in trailers in the
future though is not as dystopian to me
as it seems to be to others yeah I'd be
like that's convenient stack in the back
of man like I live in a trailer that's
amazing although getting down like he
had to do calisthenics oh [ __ ] that [ __ ]
never saw him go back up yeah that's
true man yeah idle [ __ ] you to get back
up um it it oh wait that's weird you're
right I never thought about that what do
you think I really [ __ ] dug it it's
it's a simple movie you know like it and
it reminds me a little bit just in
purely narratives tones like Mad Max
fury road which is a Mad Max is a very
very [ __ ] civil movie we're driving
to a place oh [ __ ] it's not there we're
driving back home that's all that that
[ __ ] movie is but the work George
Miller would disagree but whatever guys
like I worked on this for 10 years he
reduces it to like but like similarly
this is a very simple movie it's here's
a guy who finds out that there's an
easter egg at the it's somewhere in the
oasis and if you can find it much like
Charlie Bucket like if you can earn the
key to this castle it belongs to you you
just got to survive a bunch of heinous
[ __ ] in the Oasis really simple like
video game logic like here's the three
stages here's your big boss yeah and
then it sort of done with but the world
is so rich and that's how that has to
work like if the story's going to be
simple the world has to be [ __ ] rich
if the world is gonna be simple the
story has to be rich like Blood Simple
is a very complicated movie it's a noir
it's a twists and turns and reversals
and all of that [ __ ] but the world is
your world like you know what it is you
don't have to do any mental work to
figure out where they are and what the
rules of that world are it's our world
right but this you gotta like alright so
they can die in here but not really and
they get coins if they win [ __ ] and they
can have avatars that look like any 90s
80s character you want to look like and
okay and and
apparently you can have Iron Giant next
to [ __ ] Mickey Mouse next to Jesus
serenity from Firefly you gave all of
these things just buttered up against
each other in a world that makes sense
yeah and the work you have to do and
make that make sense is work that you
don't have to do to understand what the
story is and I think it's really
elegantly done and it's [ __ ]
Spielberg Jesus Christ like it's
Spielberg firing on all cylinders and
like you know this is a guy who's been
doing this [ __ ] since we were all just
watching it so everybody working today
you know kind of built it on and build
their trains on the track that he
already laid so it's in his [ __ ]
wheelhouse to say the least it's almost
kind of the best material of the best
match of material to director I've seen
in quite some time but and there's
nobody it's not but this is a bad but
there's about how much live action would
you say 30% maybe dance movies in not a
cartoon it's it's 70% you know previz or
the animation flat out cartoon it at a
certain point it but it sucks you in
you're never like what the [ __ ] I didn't
pay for a cartoon it's it's one of the
most satisfying pieces of animation
you've seen in a while if you sit
through the [ __ ] end credits hoping
for a easter egg guess what none but
maybe there might be when it goes to
theaters we saw it like in a
pre-screening or something like that but
anyway I watched all the credits and the
list of animators lasts about a full
minute in the crawl and goes 5 columns
long like they should have put them up
front because they're truly the stars of
the movies the people that put everybody
in the movie created the world and it's
built from the world up seems like some
of the performances are motion capture I
think so a little bit like oh thank you
Cheers look I am but it's definitely
worth a watch for sure yeah like if you
love this [ __ ] the way we love this [ __ ]
it'll just be a never-ending parade of
my kid asked me afterwards she was like
did you cry I was like twice she's like
I knew it
they said the charm of making how do you
not cry oh my god they do they said from
from Excalibur like it was crazy as they
said it on the screen I said it out loud
and my kid looked at me like what the
[ __ ] but they do the charm of making
from Excalibur now enough food the india
invasion and they say it a couple
[ __ ] times it's not just like was
that it like it's repeated and you're
like that was it is pretty fantastic
he likes that actor quite a bit he does
Mark Rylance Mark Rylance he's the one
that won the Oscar right yeah who I mean
he's really good in this I don't usually
respond to him that well but he's
playing [ __ ] Daffy billionaire tech
genius the character he plays reminds me
of the guy from real genius remember the
Val Kilmer movie he won the contest and
had the underground tunnel and Laszlo
Laszlo but yeah it's it's a stunner man
[ __ ] it's like some of my kid just told
me so know who till after the screening
the folks that were running RealD said
that like they shot this finit they
wrapped two years ago so they've been
working on rendering like all that time
and stuff and you know it looks [ __ ]
expensive it looks like they spent two
or three dollars to make this movie
that's it it's all up there on the
screen that's bail yeah but I enjoyed I
had a good [ __ ] time man as neat
hopefully we'll get Ernest Cline to come
in here and talk about it you know it's
really sweet as years ago Ernie wrote a
buckaroo banzai sequel and in the movie
there is a like a key moment that
involves buckaroo banzai where you're
just like holy [ __ ] like this dude's cut
from the same cloth as me so yeah if you
like this show particularly you'll
[ __ ] love ready player one it's kind
of what we do here just still pop
culture and [ __ ] except they've got
three acts and then 300 million dollars
and everyone's much thinner much longer
though that's true yeah yeah it's true I
will see what happens in the morning but
if everything works
it's supposed to but tomorrow morning I
will have lost 20 pounds since two
Thursday's ago see how much more we
could [ __ ] shave off of that nightly
trim no I doubt it but uh but yeah it's
it's it's it's weird
I'm watching my bar I'll be honest with
you my I lost my moves my [ __ ] [ __ ]
sucked back in I was like I got pecs
again so on my way but enough about that
let's talk about the news we got some
news man dive in man mark as always
collects all the news that's fit to
print so now it's so hard you guys hear
what he knows how long it takes me
news together mark barnard and give it
up for him ladies and gentlemen give it
up I remember sitting next to you when
we saw Justice League and there was a
there was a similarly ready player one
style squeal of Glee when you [ __ ]
parademons holy [ __ ] we got power demons
yeah you're gonna get nothing but
[ __ ] parademons because they're
making a new gods movie this this is
huge it was incredible news to me cuz I
didn't smell this coming nobody said
this was in the wind all of a sudden
they announced new gods with Ava
Duvernay
yeah which is fantastic give a big epic
to a woman but more importantly just
make the new gods like holy [ __ ] really
that means we're gonna get dark side
maybe there's the reason why they were
like or there was an offspring from
remember they're supposed to be to
Justice League movies second one likely
involve Darkseid we know for a fact it
was gonna involve Darkseid so as that
got scuttled maybe they were like
alright we could do a whole new God's
world cuz it's kind of like a game of
Thrones ii affair you know with multiple
planets warring planets and [ __ ] hi
father Darkseid a bunch of cool
characters mister miracle scot-free big
Barda the female Furies like you can go
crazy it's a whole universe and with one
movie if it really works you can launch
you know a bunch of potential sequels
that have nothing to do with bad
man Superman Wonder Woman or something
so I think it's an amazing idea but I
never saw that coming to say the least
yeah last year she tweeted out I think
was like October last year somebody
asked her who's her favorite superhero
and she said uh big Barda really yeah so
she's this has been in the works for a
while clearly one doesn't just drop that
to drop it really you don't think maybe
that got her the job she's like I said
big Barda and somebody Warner Brothers
is like oh [ __ ] let's do that I mean
I've said that I like root beer and
nobody's showing up to my house with a
carton full of root beer it's true but
he also didn't make Selma so as far as
you know but yeah they're they're
absolutely leaning into it it feels like
it's it's they're steering away from the
idea of the the connected shared
universe because they've said that this
does not directly tie into Justice
League or Aquaman or whatever else
they're doing this will be its own
standalone thing yeah it's and you know
the seems like they're like look we
[ __ ] up the DC Universe let's go to
space see what happens up in space but
yeah they they're they are aggressively
looking by the sounds of it at least DC
and Warner Brothers are looking to stake
out some new territory even though it's
going to come on the heels of you know
Thanos and it's true everything's gonna
be hard after this Avengers movie but
still it's like that's great IP new IP
they're not just doing the same thing
it's not yet another Batman movie and it
could be turned into something cool I
support that
I never thought like [ __ ] this is the
world we live in man we were like oh the
new gods movies going to follow Avengers
so it might not be cool but you know
it's I'm happy I can't believe there's
gonna be a new gods movie a dark side
we're gonna see dark side yeah and my
father and apocalypse saw all that yeah
it's all about seeing dark side
but yes we get the other ones as well
you cannot please a brother apparently
speaking of DC do you remember there was
a there was a Constantine TV show yeah
went for like 13 episodes yeah and
everybody liked them and he liked did
you guys all on board for Constantine I
saw one episode I liked it I thought he
was like you know this isn't saying much
but I liked his Constantine more than
Keanu Reeves as Constantine did you yeah
I went back and I watched that old movie
though and it's still it holds up better
than I think you think it does I'd say
[ __ ] about the movie [ __ ] I said
I liked his Constantine better than
Kiana's it's alright and you know you
got to agree with me on that yeah the
other guy was British right yeah Ryan
any of the blond hair in the trench coat
Matt Ryan has been doing his level best
to keep reprising the role of John
Constantine he was in a what about his
animated thing is John Constantine he
popped up at Harrow
yeah he was in Justice League dark
animated yeah he did the voice he is now
along with John Constantine joining
legends of tomorrow for the fourth
season oh really
he will be full time on the Waverider
for the fourth season of legends that's
a good idea man oh my god I wonder how
they swung mad I'm sure they just wrote
him a check because he wasn't busy who
needs more Matt Ryan that's Wow and and
that show wasn't on the CW now that was
NBC yeah
oh [ __ ] but yeah so that's gonna happen
although they're still not officially a
fourth season for legends of tomorrow to
see that oh my could you imagine you're
hired
Edward Dunn you yeah CWS seems like
[ __ ] again CW hasn't announced their
their pickups yet for the for the fourth
season for next year but all signs are
pointing to they're gonna do another one
of that show and he'll be on it so
smoking in cancer for you do you does he
still smoke I had got rid of that at one
point he does oh my god that is so
[ __ ] crazy true to the comics then
I thought that'd be one of the first
things to [ __ ] go he smokes silk cuts
too I remember when I went to England
for the first time I've read Hellblazer
comics and book and loved him so when I
went to England I saw pack of silk cuts
I was like that's what [ __ ] John
Constantine smokes and I bought a pack
and I am NOT John Constantine as a manly
cigarette uh [ __ ] I took lungs to
draw that I didn't have I needed help I
was like help me with other people and
[ __ ] it was tough I wonder if there's a
world in which the reason why he goes in
the wave riders to go back in time to
not start smoking oh my god dude like
you're writing a better show than we're
probably gonna sure they're gonna do
that anyway but if if they're sticking
true to Canon and he's got cancer then
how better to alleviate that than time
travel that's true I'm just saying it
makes sense but I doubt CW the shirtless
boy network is gonna go that way
there may be lots of shirtless boy shots
of Matt Ryan yeah that's true with
cancer we can see it through your chest
you're doubling down on the cancer card
move on it did you ever read the Queen
and country comic books that Greg Rucka
wrote yeah oh my god yeah yeah what was
the character's name Tara chase yeah
yeah yes somebody's doing that Ridley
Scott wait sir Ridley star Ridley Scott
and Christopher Plummer is gonna be
playing playing Tara chase that's just
for us yeah he is he is in negotiations
to take on this thing it would be his
first comic book movie I think yes but
like aliens became a comic book that's
true and I mean like it wasn't IP then
but he kind of created the IP mental aid
runner to legend feels like it's a comic
book you know but yeah this thing has
been revolving in Hollywood for a good
ten or fifteen years didn't I do
whiteout that was also Greg's is also
rocky
but Ellen Page at one point was it
attached to play Tyra Chase and I think
vague memories the medicines moved on
friend of this show or at least friend
of mine John Rogers had written a draft
of that script he did transformers and
leverage on TV and the core which is a
crazy bananas [ __ ] movie that I saw
IV on over the weekend what is that that
is the oh my god the center the earth
has stopped spinning oh yeah I remember
that like The Journey to the Center of
the Earth movie right yeah which is
weird and [ __ ] up in bonkers I can't
say it's good but it's totally watchable
and I've told about the John I was like
I don't think that movies good he's like
I wrote Catwoman I know what's good you
want yeah yeah he did I think I saw
something about that recently on Twitter
he was right and answering questions
about or something like yeah is that the
guy that's the guy who was like yeah it
was a shitty movie and suddenly Twitter
blew up was like screenwriter says a
movie he wrote his shitty well no we all
knew he's like this wasn't some open
secret he was talking about stuff that
was in the giraffe when he got there
before he got there but he said it was
never Selina Kyle yeah like we couldn't
do it you couldn't touch it that's the
first mistake it's like why I call it
Catwoman that wasn't a day with her like
oh these comic kids they'll never notice
you know now it's just like hey dude
[ __ ] vision looks like vision you
better make Catwoman Catwoman what do
you got what else you got Danny Boyle
our man Danny Boyle from the
Trainspotting world from Slumdog Slumdog
20 days later he's gonna direct the next
James Bond movie oh good for him yeah
which means that James Bond will be
eating some brains or cutting his arm
off because the dodging in 20 we're
doing heroin mmm you know bond does
heroin though right it's got a right
yeah I mean that much [ __ ] the
psychic damage he's riding that [ __ ]
white dragon all the way home no he
doesn't he has to like regenerate like
Doctor Who
then he gets to forget all that horrible
[ __ ] I call the readout of his ledger
that's been my reading of that character
forever and then they [ __ ] it up with
with Skyfall why because they gave him
actual parents who actually lived and an
actual gravestone and it's like well now
he just can't be he can't be the the
moniker that the next double-oh-seven
takes on if this is actually where the
bond people are dead it's a good flick
though it is I really beautiful and also
just like it was one of the only bond
flicks to recognize the other Bond
flicks like when he brought back the
Aston Martin like his in the garage
you're like holy [ __ ] it's the Aston
Martin and [ __ ] whole [ __ ] franchise
was built on the [ __ ] car and then
you know for years they were like I just
cars in general but that moment is a
real like draws on your heartstrings if
you've been watching this [ __ ] for years
so I like to yeah I mean and that's
that's kind of the so much of ready
player one is also doing that thing
which is God here's the thing you loved
when you were a kid let me show it to
you in a context you're not familiar
with but still works yeah nostalgia is a
hell of a drug man this is not gonna
make it on the poster but it's a series
of pop cultural handjobs each one more
satisfying than the last I am gonna
email that [ __ ] to Ernie Cline be like
mother [ __ ] you need to put this on a
poster when it goes on video he'll do
deserve somewhere series of pop-culture
handjobs Kevin Smith famine I'm bad
to show you because if you left off who
said it like it would sell a ticket or
two people be like I gotta see what that
is that's the new thumbs-up thumbs-down
it's just like it's a pop cultural
[ __ ] what else we got
Spike Lee is making a [ __ ] superhero
movie yes I don't know what's happening
anymore
I don't understand the world this is
awesome news to me Spike Lee one of my
favorite directors of all time one of
the reasons I do what I do is cuz he did
what he did and as I pointed out on this
very show he was on black panther long
before anyone else he's got the
cinematic debut of Black Panthers and do
the right thing as the kids hold up a
comic a Black Panther comic and
referenced the character saying Black
Panther eat pizza we pizza Bowie so I
would say early adapter early adopter
yeah but okay I mean I mean Inside Man
do you ever see that I love that that's
a legit wonderful film I think that if
he had decided to go this route which he
could have which was I want to make
studio movies yes I'm gonna make my own
like the sweet blood of Jesus [ __ ] on my
own dime but I'm gonna still then move
on and make big giant [ __ ] studio
movie because I can do that as well as
anybody can hmm but for him to be making
Nightwatch now that's a Marvel book that
is a deep cut Marvel book that lets you
there's like a spider-man subsidized
Letterman character you know from web of
spider-man number 97 african-american if
I remember correctly yeah I just I mean
I guess get some of that sweet coin if
you can spike but I mean look he gets to
slap a Marvel logo at the front of it I
mean yeah okay I'd rather he made static
well that's over at DC though yeah but
he doesn't seem to be you know he's not
playing for home teams I let me make a
movie it's true well maybe they're DC or
Warner Brothers though aren't in the
static business yet although as of few
weekends ago they should have
you know I mean more than the New Gods I
would have thought let's queue up static
tomorrow yeah we've got a black
spider-man right there you got a black
spider-man they're already doing it
here's our black spider-man he's got
lightning bolts [ __ ] do that yeah
well you know it would be good white
guys in space seed is like the very
least he's mixed though right
he's great grayscale what else we got
I think my friend that is it that's all
the [ __ ] news that is all the news
that's fit to print I'm just a light
news week this it's a bit of a late news
week we talked about box office already
you talked about the crazy [ __ ]
Marvel movie marathon that I'm gonna
subject my body and soul to yes for the
good of the people in the world because
somebody's got to do it you gone solo
where you bringing your family if I
brought family they would take that
family away from me No Child Services
has got to deal with these children he
took them out of school for this these
kids can't eat popcorn for 48 hours no
they can watch them do it I'm doing that
by myself and friends that I will meet
the day of and we will together ride
into Valhalla because we will have died
about halfway through Oh calm down it's
only 11 movies I know at home over of
course of a two days it's a yellow cap
seats are like Iron Maiden man those
things are [ __ ] toys that was
happening uh-huh
I'd be out well I don't know they I've
those elk cap seats are [ __ ] the Lex
Luthor to a fat man always always happen
because we live down the street or up
the street from nail cap so it's always
easy to go there and I take the kid all
the time because you know they got the
guy plays the piano and they [ __ ]
shoot confetti and [ __ ] you know you
feel like they try to put on a [ __ ]
show before the show like spring break
for kids yeah it's and it's like some
kids to watch and it kills a few hours
and stuff so we'd always go but then I'd
always have to be like like alright you
sit here I'm gonna go stand in the back
because the seats are real [ __ ] tight
and stuff like that but now maybe 20
pounds later maybe not maybe I can walk
in and be like one normal seat please
you don't even need to butter my hips we
have a guest
yes I do believe we do do you have the
phonetic sheet I committed that [ __ ] to
memory did you I did or we'll see if I
did because she will not stand by the
I'm not yawning cuz I'm bored I'm trying
to get a little more oxygen I'm free I'm
not feeling light-headed at all but I am
feeling a bit more stoned than normal
it's just with the diet I'm on it like
there's not a [ __ ] ton of food and [ __ ]
like that and my old ratio of smoke to
weight is now completely [ __ ] so so
you have a little bit's basic okay so
they're making a new warrior show they
are the Marvel is making one of those
days one of the most popular characters
recent characters have become out of
Marvel Comics in recent years is the
character of Squirrel Girl
am I correct correct indeed people love
them the [ __ ] Squirrel Girl I've been
at many Comic Cons where I've seen
people dressed like Squirrel Girl and I
was like who is that they're like you
[ __ ] fake fan
I got educated as fast as I could and
whatnot and so that show is happening in
the future
and I'm sure we won't be able to talk
about much of it I'm sure there'll be
some sort of like [ __ ] lockdown on
details but the young lady who plays or
is gonna be playing over in fact they
probably shot him plays a squirrel girl
is probably no stranger to your eyes
it's been a plenty of [ __ ] TV shows
and she was in a series of commercials
what was that one she would bang it
wasn't the gecko thing it was a TNT yeah
well done thank you audience we're gonna
talk to her and a friend of hers our
director about some new thing they're
working on and stuff we it's so rare
that we have guests on the show so give
it up big time for say the name Milan
event rude bang come on up kid keep it
going till she gets here so it's not
weird
[Applause]
that's what they call me the girl in the
gecko commercials I was I don't know I
was trying to limit the list of people
it wasn't and I went with that yeah
that's true I was wrong about that I was
probably going for progressive but I had
a [ __ ] heart attack give me a [ __ ]
break
in any of that you tweeted something
cute about getting what make it out
Jeremy watching Mallrats Bob's right
back
oh my god first like real makeout sesh
while watching that on my mom's couch
who chose the movie he did he loved that
movie he would like Emily not enough man
he's less liked this movie can wait well
but maybe that's maybe that true fan
would have waited till the credit may
because he'd already seen it he's like
we could skip this part that tongue he
was he he's very wet yeah I was a very I
remember afterwards being like Oh making
how it makes your face so sticky but
then I just learned that he wasn't great
at it oh my god that's right so he was
the first one and [ __ ] yeah hopefully
he's not listening to the show going I
[ __ ] dry what is the series of
commercials what did you do I played
Lilly which is the lady that the girl
that did what she were yes yeah she
worked at the store and Lily Adams I
mean I don't know how to break it down
to you if you haven't seen it I I'm
surprised that you've seen everything
except for that element of pop culture
what that commercial
yeah no I'm familiar okay I was saying
for the folks at home okay don't get all
I wasn't like what all of my movies I
couldn't avoid that [ __ ] commercial
it was everywhere and stuff his national
campaign yeah what is it like to get a
national campaign it makes you not broke
and that was my first time that's my
first time being not broken that was
nice was it the first big paycheck
yeah and so it's like for those that
don't follow this sort of thing there
are local ads so their spots that are
kind of run in a general area city or
somewhere car dealerships yes your
mattress stores local florists Neil with
a deal he's he's not national if you go
to New York and you're like
okay man can I get a deal though like we
don't [ __ ] know kneel here we're not
me that's here but then there are
national spots which are like [ __ ]
Burger King McDonald's coca-cola
Kentucky Fried Chicken and apparently
AT&T so when that happens how many
people from your life get back in touch
with you like it when I [ __ ] when I
had the heart attack I was hearing from
[ __ ] who were like I thought had
passed away or they thought I did and I
almost did but [ __ ] but like I was
hearing from the past yeah Cartman he
made a joke that as soon as she got
money everyone asked her to be their
kids godparent and I yeah it was all I
don't know I think I actually had more
people just be like um I I know you from
somewhere right you know I think what
happened is actually just people on the
street thought that I was a familiar
person I don't know that they saw me
enough to be like Oh mallanna is now
Lilly
so I I don't think that my life changed
that much really yeah they asked you to
buy my house to buy out might mean my
mom did freeze emerg I follow you my mom
is here actually well yeah yeah in
typical Jewish mom fashion what she
wants to do
all she wants to do for her birthday is
make other people happy
is it truly your birthday do you know
the person that said it's your mom's
birthday can be famous for your birthday
though for like a second at the bar man
what do you want to sing we could do
piano man you want to do that song song
sung blue yes let's do happy birthday
count 3 1 2 3
what's your name hold on Oh Leena o
Leena o Leena o Leena you could just fit
my flute what it's his birthday too
what's your name Michael [ __ ] you
Michael we might be able to do involve
re count 3 1 2 3
alena she's crying you made my mother
cry are you happy and heard that from so
many people right on man so and we kept
that car on the road all right so I know
you can't much talk about what you're
doing over there with new lawyers but
how did you get Squirrel Girl do you
have to audition or somebody be like
I've seen you on TV so I have to
audition you went through a process yes
yes through a process and Sean Young it
did you show up in a squirrel outfit and
like this is my jam yo nobody else but
me I did and I did also have that
mentality like they could give it to
someone else but they'd be making a huge
mistake
I've tried to do that lots of times and
they've always made a huge mistake they
were fine with confidence in work for
you not so much I don't have it very
often but I I loved Doreen Green so much
that it felt like even when I read the
comics I feel like she talks like I talk
so it made sense for me I felt really
connected to it going in and that never
happens
did you go in and costume I know I did
just are you talking about just wearing
like a headdress or did you go for I
know I wore like cutoff shorts and
leggings and boots and like uh a leotard
top hmm but I didn't I didn't wear the
ear is I kind of just suggested at the
ears Oh like like like Anne Hathaway and
[ __ ] Dark Knight Rises
remember hers were glasses then she put
them up you know like they look like
ears they look like
I get it I get it so you just sent two
that you didn't go full score I didn't
go full squirrel because I didn't want
to seem too desperate but I just wanted
to hit I wanted them to use their
creativity for them to be like I kind of
have the idea that she kind of looks
like Squirrel Girl without me being like
I'm Squirrel Girl listen to me a song of
desperation just a little a little
behind the years having been in a
position to cast people the demonic
voice never works I'm just getting
started
it works for Ben Affleck Batman ya know
he's got a voice modulator he couldn't
pull that [ __ ] off no think about it
like really Christian Bale is the last
time well Paul I ever hear somebody
people like are you serious it's like
it's got to be different bro Batman's
got a different voice and now they're
like oh it'll always be the voice
modulator they should take a pay cut for
that they don't actually have to talk
like so then they're just the body of
the Netflix having enough problems in
this world no I don't feel bad for Ben
Affleck cut to there [ __ ] in the first
episode of your show and Squirrel Girl
has a voice effect how many times did
you have to go in for an audition you go
go callbacks just one just one callback
[ __ ] a man so right away they were
like we're digging here we're digger
yeah I don't think I'm allowed to talk
about any of this done let's talk about
something else
what else you've been in I was on this
favorite children because my heart is we
watch that show I love that show my
heart doesn't work right and so in order
for me to actually have the human
emotions I have to watch that show yeah
which makes me feel it's your version of
cutting yes
yes it is cutting Plus drinking and
you've been on that show I've been on
that show yeah the first season I was in
a bunch of episodes on that that was a
joy well lovely experiment to not do
comedy it's all straight-up drama it's
all drama did you were you in a scene
that made people cry I don't know did
you cry I mean all my mom says yes happy
birthday she's a real [ __ ]
how ironic the mother of Squirrel Girl
total [ __ ] now they really don't want
you to say that I'm sure what was it
like being inside that show as it blew
up like you know I'm sure that when you
started shooting it was just another
[ __ ] show on NBC yeah I didn't know
it was going to be a huge sensation I
think the trailer had already come out
and that got millions of views that was
already viral and then once I was in it
I I was like man I really should have
worked on this harder AT&T ad [ __ ] this
what else what else well right now I
have the show out called that moment one
which is an interactive series nice
segue what is that explain so it's a
it's a show that you can play so it's
half a game half a kind of a sitcom it's
a comedy cuz that's all I'm really
capable of doing and you get to choose
what my character name is Jill you get
to choose what she does so like in the
first episode she's at a party and she
runs into a guy and she doesn't remember
her his name and so you have to play the
game to help her figure out what this
guy's name is second episode she gets
like broken up with and then you kind of
navigate that world with her it's
ridiculous but it's very funny if I do
say so myself about myself who's me
I'm sorry the guy who created his name
is Sandeep Parikh and he's here let's
bring Sandeep over to the question wall
over there otherwise it gets bar up dude
how are you sir no thanks for being here
man we all were kind of having you all
right are you a guild guy I'm a guild
guy yes yes did you watch the guilt yeah
Billie back in the day I was always kind
of like brooding that series on it was
neat that she just did it herself yeah
yeah which is a wonder she's a wonder of
the world yeah yeah all right wait so
she was setting up the show and she did
it so poorly why don't you why don't
know she did a great job why don't you
tell us that was the crater I imagine
you've got a lot of skin in the game
yeah it was uh I mean it was a beast so
I mean yeah you know your your director
so you you get that part of it yeah
putting together a show that's
interactive was was an awesome challenge
too like it's yeah we had to code our
show we had to program our show so the
whole thing is seamless like when
there's a choice moment and you've got
to choose whether or not you know Jill
remembers the guy's name or forgets it
we have the actors sort of vamping and
improvising Wow the like the timer is
ticking off and then the user will
select hopefully within that time and
it'll seamlessly cut so it ended up
being this like real sort of technical
challenges because I'm Indian I was
really good at it
so it's like Dragon's Lair with kissing
yeah pretty much awesome and with no
fear way of pitching there shall I shoot
you no no delay that was the thing I
hated about Dragon's Lair was the delay
right make a choice and then ten minutes
later you saw what happened and one
usually it was I'm bones I play and so
that's what that's what's so cold by
this thing is that like it's sort of the
choose-your-own-adventure phenomenon
that we like kind of loved so much but I
think it's it it's the promise of that
premise fully realized because you can't
like skip ahead and see if like someone
dies like your kid in the books or
whatever like your choices have
consequences they affect the story you
will get a different ending depending on
how you play it I mean it's it's like a
live action video game in that sense
that's dope how do they work where do
they watch it so that like you can't do
that on YouTube can you you you don't
watch it on the youtubes but you watch
it on the Facebook's and that allows you
to make yeah so a straight story that's
what's cool about this company echo they
made it totally like they launched it
was anybody yeah you can watch it just
on there on the website you can download
their app or you can watch our Facebook
yeah you can go to hello echo comm it
spelled ek oh and it's there you can
play it on the app you can play it on
Facebook but that was a clever thing
they didn't want you to like have to
download anything or pay anything to do
it it's free to play and but just like
but it's it smells techy like if you're
making choices while watching a video
yeah and those choices are happening in
real time and how many choices are there
one to about three every time yeah
there's like three for every choice but
is that what you mean like yeah every
time you interface like okay say you're
watching the chasing amy version of this
and you know you do you thank you for
putting into the kevin smith language so
I could understand I want to take now
I'm engaged I wanted to prove that I was
a fan and you want to choose whether
Amy's nickname is finger cuffs or Eiffel
Tower or her I see Mike you get to make
that choice and then it'll branch off
from there and there's like probably
about 13 different branches per show
kind of pulled that number on my ass but
it feels right so very different like
combinations are there like hundreds of
thousands of combinations in terms of
like unique ways that you can watch the
show there's literally you know several
hundred thousands of ways you could
watch each episode
depending on how you it's kind of
brilliant because you're making people
like if they're invested in any given
story anything I want to see cuz when I
would do a choose-your-own-adventure but
I would just keep flipping back and
forth between them you're getting views
every time somebody wants to play it a
different way and like more streams like
Star Tours but with romancin I'm just
gonna come up with other things that it
is but with romance right can we use all
these in our pitch because I don't know
how to pitch this show you know they're
all yours thank you so much that's a
lovely parting gift yeah hopefully it's
not like hopefully the experience isn't
just a grab for your reviews like we
really wanted it to be a great story
that people could kind of get behind and
get excited about Justin and like feel
like the interactivity was on like
necessary for for these not a gimmick
just ìlet ated the story for sure
it's like clue the movie but funny way
yes and way more choices right right did
you not think clue was funny no don't
ever pick a fight with these clue
[ __ ] people man I mentioned I watch
ass on the side of my face yeah sorry
I'll stand behind this wall okay I'm
with you man no clue is great you know a
clue I mean what clue has its place in
pop culture when does it begin when can
they start watching boy so much
what is the title of it it's called that
moment when that moment went so they can
go to Facebook what Facebook page that
moment when that's some good marketing
right there well done yeah
and it's up now is it there many get do
episodes get added or is it just like
episodes and you put them all up at once
and there are all the ones and there's
an overarching story and yelling follow
jail tour I don't think God so there are
[ __ ] ton of combinations man cuz like
you can do a bunch combinations in one
episode then the next episode bunch of
combinations there and [ __ ] right yeah
we shot a lot of scenes right so you'll
maybe see like five to eight minute
episode but we shot about thirty scenes
for that episode there's a lot of both
yeah I mean she had to like ingest and
spit out 28 pages a day like no joke
Wow Thank You mr. Tucci this is why we
needed the magic of was it one word per
page yeah no yeah it was it it was just
a lot well you know also Sandeep and I
are old friends and he really gets me
and I think he writes from what comes to
me naturally so a lot of what Jill said
is not so far it felt very natural and
and easy for me to learn the lines and
say it and and then we also had lots of
help we had people who like pas who
would sit with me while they were
readjusting to cameras to be like this
is your next three page monologue and
and then [ __ ] thanks yeah and and
then we also we yeah you can't help but
do improv when Sandeep casts a ton of
improvisers and so it's just full of
funny ridiculous people who want to
punch up the lines to make it their own
so it's both why do it why do what why
make it in the first place makes a show
I think for Sandeep I mean he really
seemed like we put so much of his life
into this but I also think it's an
incredible culmination of his skills and
passions he's had game nights at his
house for as long as I've known him
he had his birthday at a game house he
he's you yeah yeah he cuddles with a
game board before that's why I [ __ ]
love blue that's the game board that I
spoon so yeah I think it and and also
because he's an Indian computer
programmer I think that works yeah him
as well it was my only way to America
something like that hopefully somebody
goes we love it will finance it let's
continue know like people financed it
Johnny shouldn't have to pay for this
sony Sony would Sony crackle can I say
that echo Sony
I don't know what I could say it doesn't
matter I said it it's too late we talked
too much about Squirrel Girl we're off
the reservation yeah yeah but yeah so
all of bridge entertainment and echo
were our production company and echo was
the platform and Sony funded us so yeah
we had yet some death and I was [ __ ]
fun to do isn't it yeah I love making
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] it better than
break-in [ __ ]
oh yeah man there's two paths in life
right there's creation and destruction
and creation path is so [ __ ] fun but
it's empty as [ __ ] cuz people don't want
to try it they think oh that's only for
some people anybody could do that [ __ ]
yeah it's easy to break [ __ ] sit around
and [ __ ] on him when that but like it's
it's way more fun to go out and try
making your own [ __ ] you got a [ __ ]
series to show for it that somebody
[ __ ] paid for I was sitting there I
thought we were talking to some [ __ ]
game indie kids who were like we did it
on our own [ __ ] back you're like no I
had Sony Cash [ __ ] I mean they did pay
a Sony caster hit a Sony crackle cash I
mean everybody's figure than that right
like it's a new medium they're not gonna
like dump but you know a dump truck full
of money on us they're gonna be like hey
you're scrappy here's a little bit of
money to try something new and make it
awesome and so I feel like we took their
dollars and made it into something that
looks like
a lot more that's the hope did you know
you were always gonna put it up on
Facebook
now I think the plan was always to
potential stripping on Facebook yeah
because we wanted people to like we just
wanted people to see it I think as
easily as possible
not have any barriers you know so and I
guess that's what up the kids are on
these days [ __ ] what's that especially
if you want to steal an election
Facebook right
wait for the ruination of our country so
I mean why wouldn't would you both leave
your [ __ ] politics at home I bought
the anybody watch SNL this weekend yep
nope on the weekend update' they did
this one joke where they talked about
walmart has filed a patent for robotic
bees - you know pollinate crops this is
a real thing that they plan to do in the
future and then the Colin was like which
begs the question what is Walmart now he
was like they used to be a department
store then they're a grocery store you
could buy guns there and now they're
building a bee army and how did they
hire the professor from richy-rich deep
cuts Wow on this show that mean [ __ ]
earned your place behind the bar with
that deep cuts all right the show is
called that moment when nailed it they
can watch it right now on Facebook and
they should do so when they're done
watching this give it up for kids man
I do I do want to say one thing because
the the reason that I was super excited
to do this show is my mom's boyfriend
Oleg I'm Russian
that's my his name is Ola he's a huge
huge huge fan of yours
and he used to be in a metal punk band
and he made a cover song and he loved
what Oleg and I literally wrote the
lyrics to that song man and so he wants
to give it to you he's always wanted to
give it to you pleasure pleasure
[Applause]
so in clerks the character Olaf who has
the song Berserker is Silent Bob's
cousin from Russia a Russian metalhead
are you truly Russian so like when you
saw that movie we were like oh my god he
[Applause]
give you that that is tremendous man I'm
going to stick this image so it's a USB
Drive well I'm sure I'll be hearing from
the government very soon like he said he
was a Russian family yeah they all start
his fans that is amazing and so
wonderful for the kid who made that
movie [ __ ] 25y what is today today is
March today is 18th tomorrow's the 19th
tomorrow's today's a 19 today is the
19th this is [ __ ] up if you're
Catholic its st. Joseph's stay sure no
Catholics in this bar but this is March
19 25 years ago from
25 years ago from this moment we are
prepping to start shooting the first day
on clerks so the kid who made that movie
to hear that that [ __ ] dopey movie
shot in Leonardo New Jersey that night
travels all the way to [ __ ] Russia so
much so that a real Russian metalhead is
oh I'll cover that song and hands it to
me a quarter century later that is what
life is all about man thank you for that
[Applause]
job
all right folks now we go to [ __ ] that's
amazing
I can't wait to listen we go to the part
of the show that everybody [ __ ] loves
it's the QA part of the show where you
the audience get to ask us questions and
we try to answer them as best as we can
as always deacon at 4dx and our good
friends at 40x have hooked us up with
five pairs of tickets and we ask that
anybody ask any question they want
excuse me but you're not guaranteed to
win the tickets you got to ask a really
good question that me and and Mark can
both respond to and stuff like that so
with that being said JC as always takes
to Mike out into the audience and we
begin our Q&A what's your name sir
brandy what is it Brandon Brandon give
it up for Brandon everybody fire away
good sir what do you want to know first
of all I want to say I watched listened
to your show every day I listen to a
while job uber so it keeps me saying
drive it around these crazy people's in
in LA secondly I want to say I compare
my life I'm a Marvel here so I'll come
when I have to Doctor Strange go closer
on the mics thing I used to be something
I enjoy and I was did very well at
surgeries injury took that away from me
in a way now kind of focus on film and
from
as me staying it from the master as not
destroying will say how do I get from
here to there to this side of the bar
beeps plugged in walking around getting
from there to here I mean well it was 25
year journey that started 25 years ago
tonight but it started with one thing in
me and there's maintained that same
thing the whole journey I just I just
want to see what I want to see it's very
selfish and masturbatory and there are
others that build their career around
like hey man what's what's everybody
wanted to see because that'll make money
and [ __ ] and that's fantastic and I love
those movies but for me it was never
about like mass domination or anything
like that it was just about seeing the
stories that I never saw it sounds weird
to talk about representation in this day
and age as a [ __ ] middle-aged white
man but there was a time in my life
where I'd go to the movies and not
recognize my friends my world anything
and I wanted to see that you know I was
like I've looked for myself my whole
life I'm 47 I'm still figuring it out
but I know I never found myself in
school and I know I never found myself
in church the closest I ever came to
figuring out who I was was generally
through the arts watching a movie
reading a book listening to music
watching a TV show so for me going to
the movies and seeing representation
seeing my world like we're people I mean
it's weird to say representation now
because the world that I wanted to see
is now the world we live in like we're
in a [ __ ] bar talking about like geek
stuff like that's [ __ ] amazing when I
wrote those movies that's what I dreamed
the world would be like it wasn't just a
few of us and [ __ ] who would go to a
convention every year or something it
was everybody and and we could speak the
common language kind of like they do and
ready player one they drop a lot of pop
cultural references and stuff so for me
it was all about just make the thing you
want to see just make that world and I
keep doing that over and over again
sometimes people want to see it with me
that's been [ __ ] wonderful lately
they're like you got this we'll catch
you up later on man go make yoga hosers
but you just keep doing what you want is
this sounds crazy and stolen from
Shakespeare but
until I known self be true that's the
only way I got to this side of the bar I
mean I'm sure I could have asked for a
job and you know Tom Cruise it when he
pores he reigns but uh in terms of
getting here to be this person it was
just doing the stuff I wanted to do and
I'm sure there's a path where you could
do their stuff whatever that may be and
it might get you there as well but for
me like Indy always made sense when I
went up to film school in Vancouver they
were training us to be pas entry-level
pas in the movie and TV biz because they
do a lot of production up there but I
was like why would I like if you give me
the knowledge and how to make a movie
why would I go work for somebody else
I'm gonna take that knowledge I'm gonna
try to make my own [ __ ] thing so
that's the only way I know how to get
here man
and you know sometimes being you and
[ __ ] sticking to you is easy and
sometimes like you take a [ __ ] ton of
[ __ ] for it sometimes you'll find out
you give right later on and stuff when
we made Mallrats
everyone hated it critics [ __ ] on it
made no money ten years later I you know
I can eat out on that movie until the
day I [ __ ] die it's some people's
religion and stuff so you never can tell
but as long as you stay true to you you
can't guarantee to satisfy the audience
no guarantee whatsoever it's a crapshoot
self expressions the moment you put it
out there anybody could react in a
different way and it could be a [ __ ]
they could just hate your [ __ ] or they
could have had a bad night at home or
whatever [ __ ] before they watched it or
whatever so you have no guarantee on
satisfying the audience I mean it's a
lottery and but the in the process the
only person who could 100% satisfy is
yourself and so at the end of the day if
you make the thing you want to make so
that you're like even if the whole world
hates it and [ __ ] you're like I get it
but that's it's the exact [ __ ] movie
I wanted to make you know hopefully
you'll catch up where we'll be in sync
next time or whatever the [ __ ] or you
like it better but that way when
heartbreak comes like in the way of
Yoko's ores and stuff you're like I wish
you'd made more money but that is
literally the exact movie
wanted to make good you know critics
it's rated the movie gone like he's lost
his [ __ ] mind I'm like fair enough
cuz that's the exact [ __ ] movie it
was no accident it wasn't like this is
the best footage we had I was like oh my
god this is gonna work like crazy and it
didn't but it worked for me and that was
the important thing so today I know and
self be true you yeah I mean I think
that also the secret in what Kevin was
talking about is that he wrote movies
that only he could write he was telling
stories that only he could tell and I
think that the the currency in Hollywood
especially today more than ever his
voice what is the thing that you can say
what is the story you can tell that
nobody else can and figure out what that
is and tell it because today that's
that's the the currency of the realm is
what is your story and I was a different
from every story we've ever heard ever
before you know and I think that if you
can figure that out if you can figure
out what makes you different what sets
you apart how that the the myriad of
choices that you've made Clues style to
get to this point nice callback thanks
to get to this point inform the work
that you do you know like I I come into
the world as a writer and that's how I
that's how I roll Kevin is a writer as
well and also makes movies I'm not sure
what your how your particular bow is
bent but whatever it is find the version
that only you could do and then that'll
be the version at the end of the day
gets you what you're looking for does
that make sense
that's a great question give it up for
him ladies dummy get some tickets
thank you very well we got next JC who's
up boy Michael how are you how are you
sir I'm very well thank you I am 34
today holy [ __ ] yeah
and 13 years ago I actually had a heart
attack myself what I was 21 years old
what a ripoff man like any not gonna lie
I was a senior in college it was pretty
awful
I lost 85 pounds in that time actually
you were heavier than I was heavier I
was a smoker very stressed out but I was
working at a great place in Tucson
Arizona
Canyon Ranch health resort it's a
wonderful place I've been there yes not
to say that but yes I've seen you a few
times sir we've got a couple occasions
that's right it's supposed to be like
you can't [ __ ] say I don't know who's
there ever never been there it's a place
my wife likes to go in Tucson Arizona
Canyon Ranch it's like a spa like yeah
yeah but when you say health spa people
like fat farm and they're like this
ain't no [ __ ] platform this is
expensive but like it's beautiful in the
outdoors there's lots of programs if you
like doing those a wonderful place and
I've learned a lot since then I've been
there since I was 17 years old well one
of the things that I I haven't learned
and I've still struggled to today and
I'm asking both of you because I think
this is a safe space for me my favorite
thing in the world is Star Wars
yeah and yesterday when I went to work
my office was decorated by my staff with
nothing but Star Wars stuff and I was
almost embarrassed almost ashamed of it
because I want to be identified and
known for more than that because I like
a lot of things I like a song of ice and
fire and just a myriad of things so my
question to you the two of you is how do
you get past that self-consciousness of
or that embarrassment level of loving
what it is that you love because I I
love Star Wars and I and I watched Clone
Wars and rebels and I've really started
to really like the prequels right
[ __ ] you run you run deep I mean it's
right it's all right I would ask your
advice how to get past my own
self-consciousness of embracing it is
that it is that you love the only thing
I could say toward that is because I
that's my whole schtick since day one
it's been like these are the things I
[ __ ] like I've always tried to be
more an advocate than a critic and early
in my career I would be both I would be
like these are the things I like and
these are the [ __ ] who I think
[ __ ] things up and the older I got I
was just like you know what nobody needs
to know what I think about the [ __ ]
in fact just spread the good [ __ ] the
bad like you know like why throw a
negative vibe out there in the [ __ ]
first place so I
have always kind of embraced the weird
and the [ __ ] minutiae and the and the
geeky and stuff I might not have a
career if I didn't make a lot of Star
Wars comments in my first movie and the
movies after that and stuff but I will
say this like I
it wasn't until I guess it was gern that
well it was since I became a STONER so
I've been a STONER now for 10 years and
you could probably find the moments like
on SModcast where I finally come out and
talk about being a STONER but right
there everything for me got more
emotional bless you like I I as things
that I loved I loved so much more so as
much as like you know I [ __ ] loved
Batman I'd be blazed and [ __ ] reading
or watching Batman be like this is my
life you know just really embracing it
and stuff so by the time I got to that
flash video I put up a video of me
watching the season finale of season one
of the flash which is like one of the
greatest hours of programming ever
produced on television and and it
follows a breathtaking [ __ ] season
and stuff as crazy emotional insanely
well done and before I was watching the
whole season Jason Mewes I was on
citizen you know I joined them on season
2 I started watching Jason Mewes was
like you gotta record yourself watching
the season finale and I said why and he
goes because it's so emotional he goes
you know me I'll cry at anything and I
almost cried because but I know you
everything makes you cry so like I want
to see how hard this makes you cry and I
was like okay and so I when I watched I
set up the camera to record myself and
put it up on the YouTube channel you
could still see it to this day and to
say I cry is an understatement
crying as a Native American by the side
of the road looking at garbage you know
that's crying dignified one lone tear I
am like bawling look at my tits are
going up and down hit me in the face
blubbering I'm so [ __ ] like emotional
about it and I opted to like post that
like I was like I'm gonna put this up
there and it led to a lot of people
going oh [ __ ] he cries at that [ __ ] too
like it opened a door for a bunch of
people to be like I get crazy stupid
emotional about this [ __ ] as well so
you know I risked ridicule but I was a
STONER so I give a [ __ ] you know I was
just like ass gonna do it's funny to me
like I loved for years this [ __ ] has
always made me emotional and emotionally
invested in [ __ ] pop culture and the
stories I love Star Wars [ __ ] Batman
like everything that I dig I go deep
into and stuff and then even describing
things like to other people I was trying
to describe ready player one to my wife
when I got home and I start crying she's
like enough I'm not interested yeah
cuz once the waterworks comes out she's
like oh my god like she walked in the
other day and she's like I was up early
and she woke up about 10 o'clock and she
was dropping off one of the other dogs
so she's like Kevin Luiz here and she
opens the door to my office and like I'm
tears streaming down my face my face is
red my eyes are glassy and stuff and she
goes oh my god what happened and I was
just like Mickey Carter died man they
were friends you know and she's like
who's Peggy Carter I was like Captain
America and she was like oh and slams
the door instead so she's found no new
respect for it but she's seen it like
all our years together two decades she's
seen me cry ever [ __ ] that others would
say his dopey but by embracing that and
just leaning into it and stuff like that
was very liberating for me so people now
expect they're like he really likes this
[ __ ] in a big bad way and there are some
people that come like watch the show but
for that reason not just because we
talked about to see me cry but to not
just because we talk about pop culture
but because we talk about it like
religion like this show
kind of like going to church and stuff
we're just preachers preaching the good
word about some one [ __ ] [ __ ] exactly
amen
so I think by going whole hog and
embracing it that's that's the way to be
there's no shame in this [ __ ] at all
particularly now we're not talking about
like this is 1991 and you want to put
your foot out there toe the waters to
see what people think of you as a Star
Wars fan Star Wars fans are everywhere
and dominate the culture and dominate
the [ __ ] business landscape left and
right so it's not like people are gonna
be like what is the Star Wars you talk
about weirdo they're gonna be like oh
let me tell you I'm sure there are a few
right yeah [ __ ] them like oh my god like
Star Wars makes life better somebody
doesn't understand that [ __ ] them hard
thank you I I always feel like this
stuff that you're really a fan of like a
deep for real fan of is a [ __ ] you are a
fan of when you were a kid right like
Star Wars or sports or music or whatever
and nobody looks at you funny if you're
wearing like a Yankees baseball cap
unless you're in LA but you're a local
sports team it's fine to be a fan of
sport it's fine to be a fan of music you
wear a concert tee nobody looks at you
funny the idea that you should have to
in any way feel internalized shame about
loving Star Wars think it's
fundamentally the same thing it's a
thing you loved when you were nine you
know and you carry that love with you as
long as you keep it within like it's
gotta be professional person you're also
not showing up in the [ __ ] chest
paint of the Seattle Seahawks like no
man I swear I'm the a in the Seahawks
today now you're an [ __ ] if you
should have to work that way you know
but like if you have to be professional
in the world you can still love the [ __ ]
you love as long as you love it within a
socially acceptable sort of modulation
but you can't wear a Slave Leia outfit
uh not at work that day at Cambridge
place everybody's wearing it but like
you know I I before I had identified as
anything else identified as a nerd like
that's always who I was you know like
before before I knew I was a black kid I
knew I was nerve this is I grew up in
the Bronx and everybody was [ __ ] black
so the thing that separated me from them
was that I loved kiss and Godzilla and
kung-fu movies and Star Wars that's
funny man that's genius like it's the
only thing that made me different I
embraced it you know until you get to
high school and you hide all that [ __ ]
because you like you want to have a
girlfriend and they don't quite get it
yet but they would come around or they
came out of the nerd closet in their own
due time but like in the world we live
in today yeah Kevin's right everybody
loves something and as long as you can
treat that love with respect and treat
everybody else's love with respect and
we can all get along you know and if you
got people that like don't get it like
Star Wars this is childish just get real
with them so [ __ ] fast you know like
true or not just feel like well I saw
Star Wars with my father when I was a
child and now he's dead so this is the
thing that makes me feel closest to him
right well then in there okay well good
for you Michael
and then there's the [ __ ] if you
cannot win their understanding by simple
like [ __ ] have you ever seen Star Wars
that's why I like it then just hit them
with the real real man be like Oh cuz
it's for a far deeper reason than you
could ever possibly imagine this has
something to do with dead relatives you
[ __ ] and you know insensitive clod
and then they'll never ask you again
thank you excellent question get bigger
well Michael happy birthday my man
wearing a [ __ ] stormtrooper helmet
yes that's the way to come these were
not the questions you were looking for I
doing guys hey Mark first of all how are
you feeling are you the vegan diet now I
have been told I have to be on a
plant-based diet which what's up ketchup
and burgers I don't know
it's a little like though you can still
have some meats just not the ones you
like but I'm good thank you I'm glad I'm
sorry to missed your signing take this
guy to pick him up from France but any
role that way to France
no well LAX for many many hours what was
the signing last how'd it go yeah well
we sold out so and then after was the
night that I went to the emergency room
Oh fine anyways my question is besides
the sixties because you know Green
Hornet and Batman can't be touched what
TV show would you guys tackle between
the 60s to the 90s and why hmm from 60s
to 90s well or no 70s tonight I mean
that it wasn't like well it's weird
because this came from movies first but
you could get away with doing Buck
Rogers in the 25th century which was a
TV show that I enjoyed when I was a kid
I mean it was born out of the Star Wars
successes they started trying like
Baltar Galactica and then I tried Buck
Rogers but it was a movie first like
what was an old cereal back in the day
but then it wasn't Buck Rogers
originally a movie release and then a TV
show I don't think so that battle star
did that who did which one yeah they put
the two first two episodes together of
Buck Rogers yeah but that's a pretty
rich fertile universe and the idea we
haven't reached the 25th century yet so
it's still the future and stuff I
probably get away with that you
Airwolf oh my god yes it's a giant
[ __ ] helicopter that can do
loop-de-loops and and blow [ __ ] up real
good and that hides out in a mountain
because that's where you hide a
helicopter because nobody's got
satellites or other helicopters to look
down and see the [ __ ] helicopter
don't care the dude's name is sin Jim
why do you not have a TV show with a guy
named Sinjin on it
and Stringfellow the best name ever so
yeah you watch the [ __ ] out of this show
man I was everybody cool am a Larsen
[ __ ] know where's that Donald
Belisarius one of the two Donnell
military's I think it was yes with a
Mike post score [ __ ] yes
this was Jan Michael Vincent uh-huh
Ernest Borgnine with the same shot they
were used over and over from in the
cockpit pretty much in the same shot of
the [ __ ] helicopter coming out of
that but right not beaut cuz boots are
boring word to say but but way better
but yeah wolf can I throw in another
choice of course so it's a weird
connection but I'll take you there I I
made a movie years ago with Bruce Willis
hold on I used to love the TV show
moonlighting grew up on that's where I
fell in love with Bruce Willis had the
moonlighting soundtrack that used to be
my sexual soundtrack my friends would
make fun of me because I put on
moonlighting though what Kevin's gonna
[ __ ] exactly so I loved [ __ ]
moonlighting I love the Al Jarreau song
that Mark was about belt now then I
worked with Bruce Willis and I could
never listen to moonlighting again yeah
but then just tonight I looked for a
particular Spotify playlist slow grooves
eighty slow grooves is a pretty narrow
list but like I knew they'd have at
least six songs that like I felt like
hearin in that playlist happened to be
moonlighting and I was like I'll [ __ ]
I want to change it then I was like you
know what like you're not mad anymore
that's just some story you [ __ ] tell
yourself like listen to moonlighting you
used to love this song you used to [ __ ]
to this song
so I listen to moonlighting as I was
driving here and ended up I was coming
off of Mulholland and at a certain angle
it's the LA skyline and it looked like
the opening credits to moonlighting so I
was like oh [ __ ] how magical and whatnot
I was blazed so there you go
but at the same time moonlighting is a
show you could totally they kind of read
did it with castle that was kind of the
same similar idea but I loved the story
of David Addison and Maddy Hays and it
could totally work today
quick side question did he reach out
after Bruce he did once years later last
year within the last year he that story
yeah yeah but I haven't heard from him
since I will give you one more Spenser
for hire ooh I love me some [ __ ]
Spenser for hire I love that based on
books yeah yeah series of books yeah
like 40 or 50 of those books yeah but
yeah these sort of erudite Boston
detective who loves cracking heads and
love crackin open a good bottle of
Beaujolais was his buddy Hawk Hawk every
Brooks is Hawk who the only reason I
watched these nine was because they
promised me that Hawk was gonna be the
captain at Deep Space nine and it took
him three seasons from the shave his
head and grow the goatee oh yeah Carly
Carly yeah
and I was also if I remember correctly
was that a bill Simon de Mayo I think it
was scripted thing like there were guys
who are always the comic-book guys on TV
that did flash they wrote The Rocketeer
one of them just passed away
Bilson yeah weird tomato and what's one
of the other but yeah great they were
the Kabul go-to guys and really rang the
bell like throughout the 80s and 90s and
in a way we're like this material is
fertile you could do stuff with it they
laid the track that all these other
[ __ ] movies and TV shows you know
travel on now
that's a great question give it up
formally thank you
who lies you hey what's your name Steve
give it up to Steve everybody what can
we do you for Steve well first of all
this is kind of in honor of my sister
who sent me down years ago with your
whole librarian said you got to watch
all this [ __ ] this dude is saying some
amazing stuff so in honor of her she's
like the best person that I've ever met
in my life
um how has family influenced you guys in
your writing and I would say
specifically mark your fiction writing I
know you've had some pieces that are
truthful about your family that are
really impressive and moving but how is
that influenced the fictional worlds
that you guys have spun my sister
without my sister and my brother I
wouldn't do what I do today my sister
was the first one I introduced me to the
notion of writing you could write
something that wasn't schoolwork or
homework or something like that
I found this composition notebook she
had and opened up the cover and inside
there was a drawing hand drawn by her of
her and her friends they were kneeling
around this cellar door and I think it
was called the secret of the cellar door
and then inside writing handwriting all
over these pages and [ __ ] like Kevin
Spacey in seven but years before that
happened and we probably shouldn't
mention Kevin Spacey anymore so I I said
what is this and she goes oh I'm writing
a book and I was like eight seven or
eight at the time and I was like what do
you mean you're writing a book she's
like I'm writing a book about me and my
friends finding this door going on this
adventure and I was like you can't write
a book you got to ask the government or
something and she was like what are you
talking about anybody could write a book
because in my head I'm like books came
from a library or a bookstore and she
she wasn't she wasn't talking about
publishing a book she's talking about
writing a book and so captured my
imagination she's the first person I
ever knew that did that so years later I
was seven eight then I wrote my first
piece of writing like my own on a
typewriter when I was 12 and I gave it
to my brother the other part important
the story my brother Donald's my sister
Virginia introduced me to writing my
brother Donald was my single best
audience still is to this day
he has such an amazing laugh and if you
get him laughing he starts bawling and
he can't talk and [ __ ] he goes into the
silent scream cry of just like you know
we've taken all his oxygen it's like you
control him like a puppet and stuff if
you can put the right combination of
words together so I did that I wrote a
story about us going to like visit
relatives which we did every [ __ ]
week and it was very satirical and
turned the relatives into like monsters
and caricatures of them and stuff and my
brother thought it was hysterical and I
remember sitting next to him I typed it
all is on like four pages six pages and
then he was the first person I handed it
to and I was like will you read this he
said what is it and I said something I
wrote and he goes all right you start
reading it and then I watched him slowly
engaged with the material and slowly
like start laughing and getting to the
cry thing and I felt like I was a wizard
like with some magic words with the
words placed in the right order
I literally controlled his voluntee
involuntary
you know of nerve system I controlled my
brother I can make him laugh that felt
[ __ ] amazing and so those two set me
on the journey they never sat down and
said yeah be a writer or something like
that
but one live by example and the other
validated my first shot at it and stuff
and still to this day you know validates
everything I do so I would definitely
say family played a big role my parents
were oblivious my dad took me to the
movies all the time and that's the
credit I always get my dad he never said
you can do this like we didn't come from
that world where you told kids things
that probably wouldn't happen to them or
something like that like that's my
father thought it'd be cruel if he said
oh you could make a movie like if
anything I'm sure he thought you know
keep eating they'll make a movie about
you one day or something like that so he
couldn't conceive of it but that was our
thing together like we didn't have
support so he's like oh two fat one
likes movies we'll keep going to the
movies and stuff and you know it's not I
don't make movies because like I have
this positive association with my father
but
he's part of the matrix he was the guy
that brought me there he was the guy but
felt it was important enough to go see a
movie to pull me at a school on
Wednesday at noon before you know three
hours before school began which was like
what like you're pulling me out of not
just school but Catholic school so
you're saying [ __ ] the government and
[ __ ] God you know to some degree but the
movie was more important in stuff so dad
played a role there as well without ever
having said you should try this one day
mom well it played the role of not and
I've know this because I just watched a
tape fairly recently tape I made for my
parents before I went to film school I'm
leaving to go to Vancouver film school
it's 1992 and I make this video I borrow
this video camera from my friend Kim
Walker my ex-girlfriend Kim Loughran and
I make this video for my parents no I
mean the only way to describe is the
vlog it's essentially what kids do today
if I can just make it a vlog I set up
the camera and I give this 20 minute
goodbye and thank you to my parents
before I head off to film school and
it's really weird and creepy because I
predict the future I'm just like I'm
gonna go be an artist gonna be parents
of an artist
imma do something for this family name
and we gotta get you out of this town
like I'm going off to be a filmmaker I'm
gonna come back and make a film like it
was all true it was crazy yeah I watched
the video I'm like how did this kid know
and the weird thing about the video is
the kid in the video is so [ __ ]
earnest like he's so deadly serious we
just did it recently on SModcast you can
hear it if you're interested and you're
like that guy made clerks like there's
no sense of irony or humor whatsoever
but what I got out of the video is this
I really loved my parents and still do
but like I was never one of those people
whose own [ __ ] parents man I was the
last one to leave the house my brother
and sister had went off to college like
at the age you're supposed to and stuff
like that I stayed with my parents I
went away to college in Manhattan at one
point and then [ __ ] dropped out and
then went home and went to the Vancouver
Film School dropped out came home before
that I dropped out of like [ __ ]
Brookdale Community College I did not
show much promise whatsoever but my
mother never once said like you got to
do this you got to do that the only
thing she says you
to have a job and I had a job mostly it
like convenience stores and stuff and
she was fine with that bless you but my
brother and sister would be like you
know they went off to college they were
doing [ __ ] in the world and they would
ask my mom all the time like why won't
you got a dude like don't let him be
this guy he's just living here in the
house like he's not doing anything like
he was he's do sketches in high school
in a talent show what's he doing what is
he gonna do with his life and my mother
never asked or forced the issue and you
know probably is because she was like I
like having the last one home I was the
baby so once I left [ __ ] there were no
more kids there but she never pushed me
until one day I grew at my own rate and
became who I would become and that's
invaluable you know and it's something
that was passed down to me because when
my kid was like I don't want to go to
college I was like you really don't have
to men like you know what if you want to
go to college one day and you decide to
they'll never get rid of that [ __ ]
because they take your money so you
could totally go to college don't have
to be when everybody else does it like
develop at your own pace at your own
rate and stuff and that's what my mom
did for me so the four people you know
my immediate family is my mom dad my
brother and sister had a big role to
play and who would I Deven chily become
and what I would do you my grandfather
was born in 1900
Wow yeah turn the century [ __ ] he was
that he was a century baby so when I was
born in 71 he was already a senior
citizen you know when he died when he
was 96 and I didn't know anything about
his life really because so much of it
happened decades before you know almost
a century before I was born and just
that idea of the window on a century and
what that must have been like and like
oh [ __ ] today we have radio oh [ __ ]
tomorrow the TV's color like oh [ __ ] and
like just just trying to fill in the
blanks of his life after he passed away
was this beginning exercise in just
character building and like you know the
the ballad of Sarah Lewis is what I had
called it because I just didn't know
what it was I mean Vincent [ __ ] like he
drove a truck between New York and
Washington DC during the war because he
was too old to fought it so what was in
the truck and I'm talking venting like
spy [ __ ] and I'm just I'm doing all that
stuff you do was like a 22 year old
person who's just trying to start to get
into the fiction writing and it just it
it helped me begin that process of
understanding what could make people
tick and also blowing [ __ ] way out of
proportion and not having anybody around
to tell me I'm wrong
which is kind of great cuz my mother
would never be like no no he didn't do
any of that [ __ ] oh no your
grandmother's his second wife what yeah
write that into the story did he was an
international man of mystery as far as I
was concerned but like that was just the
sort of beginning of me
just looking at that character and
looking at people looking at like
interior lives and imagining what that
might be like and then it was my son was
nine he came her from school one day
this was like five years ago he comes
home from school and like nine years old
it's about when they start teaching
American history but not well you know
it's just like that greatest is we went
to the moon blah blah blah and there
were presidents and Revolutionary War
and whatever and so he comes home you
sit next to me he's like dad I'm not
sure I want to be black and I said okay
we're talking about this now because
every other question was like so Pluto
and goofy of both dogs but one of them
could talk why like a legitimate
question from a nine-year-old but this
was more than I was about ready to deal
with was like okay why explain to me
he's like what because they're slavery
it's like yeah all right so we're gonna
do this now it's okay like nobody's
gonna come and take you away nobody's
gonna come take me away like it's over
it's distant history it's it's in the
past
he's like ah all right and I moved on
because that's what you do when you're 9
like nothing sticks everything just
glistens off the surface but that
conversation inspired me to write the
thing that I have been waiting to read
my entire life because he asked me this
question why do I have to be black and
why was there ever slavery and I wrote a
thing and that thing got me the job at
Castle Rock and that thing is opening
doors for me that I never could have
imagined because you don't think of
those questions you know like when
you're a grown-ass person and you're
like oh no what should I buy today these
jeans look awesome in my ass but
real question do you say that when you
shop I kind of do cuz you get that like
octagonal mirror that like shows you
[ __ ] like Game of Death style so yes I
mean my family has booked ended in a
very real way the kind of life that I
have today and the the the curiosity I
have about story and character and the
worlds that you can build in fiction
that maybe should be the world you live
in today or not
but yeah it's it's absolutely you are
the people you bring with you through
life and what you do in that life can't
be divorced from that beautiful great
question all right JC once it tickets
left no pressure
hey hey nice to meet you both I'll try
not to I'll turn it to gosh big fan
Zeebo thank you a game Lucas give it up
for Lucas I hope you I hope you like the
tea that was yours thank you and I got
the note as well thank you yeah I am a
team in just actually I thought I'd have
a dumb question but it's actually oddly
relevant with Sandeep and I I'm a writer
but I'm also getting into education and
work my professor I'm working with or
experimenting and getting into virtual
classrooms with getting a grant for five
VR headsets nice and as writers both of
you what do you think are the narrative
potentials of like VR because you know
Alejandro iñárritu is doing his
experimental VR film what do you think
of the narrative potential these extra
media type things like 4dx even brand
pitch yeah but all these extra things
beyond just the two-dimensional screen
and the soundtrack you know like how do
you think these new technologies will
change storytelling the way that sound
talkies did and color I think in the
case of VR it's it's just a completely
different experience
it changes storytelling as well you
can't do three-act structure in the VR
world it's more experience all the VR
world is more about going into a theme
park like you know you don't watch a
movie about a theme park you go into the
theme park can you go into all these
places I mean obviously we saw ready
player one tonight and they express it
poetically and beautifully all
throughout that movie so I think like
it's it's a lot of people try to compare
the two because you know it's a film the
medium to some degree at least for now
but I I think it's a weird fit for most
storytellers because you want to tell a
story but VR doesn't demand a story it
demands you know what man's like
sensation like it's it's looking for
it's looking for spectacle honestly but
it's sort of like audience participation
somewhat like that moment when I guess
totally is that like taking away agency
from the author is it taking agency away
from the author well I mean if they base
it on IP that previously existed maybe
but like generally the people that make
this stuff they're the authors of it so
they're there they're the ones making
the choice to be like I want to tell the
story this way they're ahead of the
curve like the that moment when is
experimenting with or achieving multiple
arc storytelling like you can't compete
with that like if you're the Avengers
unless it's like who do you want to win
this fight
you know ring in now and we're not there
yet and stuff so they're already kind of
ahead of the curve doing something
different but the VR experience seems to
be more about create a place and let
people come and do their thing in it to
some degree it's weird I keep trying to
get my head around how to do something
in it and I've talked about before
there's this Jay and Silent Bob VR thing
that really upstart or something I know
we're working on it they're just closing
this deal
and the idea is it's because I you know
when somebody when they were breaking VR
down to me and then they let me put on
the helmet and I went in underwater and
[ __ ] I was like oh my god but then they
were like we are interested in you to do
some stories and I was like how long
like 30 minutes of content which they'll
break up into like five minute vignettes
or whatever the [ __ ] but it's not the
way that I always think of like oh we
got to tell a story in that time they're
like no it's it's an experience you got
to build something in which maybe a
story happens maybe it doesn't but it's
experiential so I was trying to like
think of how to play with the
environment in the way that makes sense
and with those characters you have one
character who does all the talking and
one character who says nothing so you
know the only problem with VR right now
is generally speaking the interactivity
is not quite there yet there's some
games in choices you the VR player will
be Silent Bob and so you put on the
helmet and you look over and Jay is just
and you know we should do this look at
that [ __ ] and then you look over there
and stuff like that so I figure that's a
way in for me it's not telling the story
but that character number one it's
easier on me because I'll have to be
there you are Silent Bob so it's like
Jay and Silent you you don't want them
to model you you don't want them to put
you in the game well I think it's better
if the audience is the guide if they
look down they'll see like you know
hands that are dudes but probably not
mine but it's like but it'll definitely
be Jay you know because you're gonna
turn over and see him and you love to do
it I mean I won't even tell them we're
shooting some they'll just turn a camera
on
just get a day's worth of footage and
that's the game what about you sir yeah
I mean it's it it will require an
entirely new set of narrative tools you
know to tell a story in that environment
including the reason why you're in that
environment you know most of the VR that
I've seen is like you're skiing or
you're scuba diving or you're at a
concert where it's just like look you
can you're on the stage and there's the
me go see like the beagles are there
they point back at you is exhausting but
that's not a story
like that's not that's an experience
it's an experience like there there will
have to be some like hard thinking on
how you convert that into a narrative
space and a lot of game designers have
done a lot of that thinking already
because ultimately a first-person
shooter is you're in the middle of a VR
experience you're deciding where you
look you're deciding where you go but
there's cutscenes to keep you in a story
generally speaking right like on the
game but there there are games that are
just literally like all right from point
A to point B follow this thing you're
there's there's a waypoint on the
horizon and you're going there and the
game is evolving as you're playing it
but VR wouldn't give you that level of
interactivity I think you decide what
you look you don't decide what you do so
I think that it will require somebody
being Alejandro be it Kevin be it
whomever you know David Lynch on some
like week-long peyote trip will come up
it's like I've cracked it but yet it'll
be an entirely different set of
storytelling like you can't really cut
in VR like there's no edits in that
story unless there's it's all a single
take it's all like [ __ ] rope they're
all these these long uninterrupted and
edit montage is one of the very
foundational tools and storytelling on
in cinema but if you don't have it how
are you telling the story how are you
involving pace and time and and
propulsion narrative Lee and experience
on how can you control pacing when the
video gets an old video game question
how do you control pacing of a story
when the player is the main character
well you throw a bunch of [ __ ] Adam like
that's what happens at the end of the
game of a game like it's the boss fight
but you should happening and you're
running in a jumping and this happens
boom and you kill them in and there
and a girl and a cake but I think that
that that this will require some really
hard thinking on how to do the things
that that cinema lets you do with
narrative and audience participation and
experience but in a virtual space and I
also think to some degree they're not
I don't think VR is gonna figure out how
to make storytelling work like how to do
traditional storytelling they're just
going to do their own thing like it's
kind of punk rock where you could just
be like look we know for courts to we're
just gonna play them way differently so
there's a chance that they don't ever
Bend and start telling conventional
storytelling in that mode like why would
you there like every time I speak to
somebody in the world of VR they're just
like you got a take off the old headset
to think about this like you can't put
it through the prism of three-act
structure this is completely different
it's experimental as [ __ ] so I you know
I look forward to the days when it's
like the Oasis like they showed us in
ready player one that should look dope
I'd [ __ ] abandon the real world for
that and a heartbeat then wife and child
[ __ ] both like get to drive around
you get to be the Iron Giant if you want
holy Silent Bob yeah I've been that
that's a character I'd play yeah
probably lamely I'd get into the Oasis
and be like I'm gonna choose Silent Bob
yet again as long as you made it with
like the wall-e chairs that just like
ferry you through your life and you're
in the Oasis but being just magnetically
drawn with cupcakes you drink through a
straw
I look forward to Walley world
that's a great question give it up for
him ladies Joe you win the tickets to
get these tickets and get these well
done well [ __ ] yeah me that brings us to
the unhappy ending of things sadly man
all things come to an end and this is
one of those things you have a good time
tonight ladies
[Applause]
such a good time doing the show I love
doing this show when are we doing the
show again next Tuesday
oh [ __ ] what so there's another
opportunity to come see us right here at
the scum and villainy Cantina in
Hollywood California give it up for the
bar they are our home ladies and
gentlemen and give it up for the guy
without whom there is no fat man I'm
Batman the man standing next to me on my
left my coast mr. Marc Bernardo and that
is fat man I'm Batman for this week I'm
Kevin hi I'm mark Renard tune in next
week same fat time same fat channel
SModcast calm or you too becomes last
Kevin Smith
[Applause]
[Music]
you